uh yeah going on to other fandoms so
jojo fans so can we talk about jojo fans
the locusts of the anime community
because
they are the relocus the religious
plague of the anime community
they're the frogs then moses rained down
no no i mean we can't we can't should
talk i mean we can't shoot no
we go but we can [ __ ] talk because we
are in that thing no no because we we
are in that fountains we're jojo i feel
like we're varying degrees well that's
varying degrees yeah like there's like
it's it's like a gradient right
and you you've gotten better recently
but i went to my god i went to rehab but
my god when conor discovered jojo
he was the most annoying jojo fan
you could ever imagine yeah in the
church of jojo he went from like altar
boy to the pope
like he just ascended like
everything has to be jojo it's like when
did you like first
properly get into jojo because it was it
when you were like in peak jojo
because i'm curious because from my
point it's gonna happen
it kind of happened out of nowhere so i
had
watched when i was moving house once i
downloaded
uh because only at the time uh only
stardust crusaders had finished yeah
before part four started and uh i
downloaded it all and i was like well
you know this this guy talks about it a
lot on youtube and says it's quirky
and and i i [ __ ] hated the art style
i thought a little bit about
[ __ ] why is it so [ __ ] ugly yeah
which is what i hear a lot from jojo
fans and i i totally understand it's
it's downloaded it because i mentioned
it yeah you've
created a monster oh my god he did this
oh my god the scientists the creative
frankenstein you're like maybe you would
you had a part to play in the catalyst
if like if you didn't
you didn't start it but maybe you
definitely accelerated yeah yeah so
uh i downloaded it and i was moving
house and i had no internet for about a
week
um and it didn't even take me a week to
make three days yeah so i watched and
got oh my [ __ ] god dude stardust
crusaders part one the first watch
[ __ ] boring yeah that [ __ ] was so
long yeah really
was there an orangutan there was a boat
what is that iraqi
i mean now now i love it yeah now it's
hilarious no i think it's amazing but at
the time i'm like i hate this i hate
this so much part two had a good thing
going yeah why are you ruining it
yeah part one okay here's what it is
right and i i i sympathize a lot with
jojo fans who come no don't change your
fans people who want to get into jojo
who are like yeah
i just can't get into it yeah it's hot
yeah yes it is hard to get into
it is it is just such a weird thing and
it's so different from what you're used
to here i say it's an acquired taste
i think some parts it is and and there's
a almost a lot of people now who
really want to like it just to get the
memes yeah yeah
and it's like you don't have to i don't
care if you do or don't which which is
the biggest thing about jojo fans i want
to say is that please stop trying to get
absolutely everyone into jojo yeah not
everyone should get
to jojo because it's not something that
appeals to everyone yeah
and it is a commitment as much as i like
i have to
basically say to people if you make it
past stardust crusaders you're probably
in for the long run yeah yeah but
that is nearly what like 70 episodes
it's 48 plus yeah it's about seven years
it's like 20 volumes of the month
so asking someone to be like hey it gets
good
72 episodes into the point of like no
return it's like
that's a hard sell anyway so i i'll get
back to that so i watched it and then i
kind of was like didn't think anything
of it like yeah and then i watched part
four
and i was like this is really good part
five hadn't came out i was
adamant on uh i actually tried to read
the manga yeah but i couldn't i couldn't
do it i was like really yeah because i
at this point i didn't start reading
manga yeah yeah strictly not reading
manga yeah
so i was like no i can't do it i've read
the first chapter of part five and i was
like no
yeah yes why who's this [ __ ] jordan
so then i started watching part five was
it ad i got about three episodes in and
i was like
i really want to know what happens yeah
and so i started reading ahead and then
it became like
i read part five in like uh like a day i
think
yes and then i read part six the next
day
and then i read part seven over like two
three days and part seven was like by
far my and part seven is when i think it
solidified like my obsession with it
yeah yeah
part seven was so [ __ ] amazing yeah
and if you have finished all the ma
all the anime yeah and you're one of the
anime only peeps who i like i was for a
long time
please give it a shot the manga is so so
good yeah past six and seven's manga is
so good yeah then i became like obsessed
and i was like okay well
i want to go back and read all the manga
now because i feel that like it was kind
of a
really different experience and i got to
go through it a lot faster yeah
a lot of the pacing issues i felt in the
anime at least for part three yeah could
be resolved yeah
with the market so i went back yeah we
watched it and i just became fully
obsessed
and i think whilst i was reading part
seven i was meeting up with you a bunch
and i suddenly became more annoying
yeah because like the thing i hate about
jojo fans
is that they they like they assume that
nobody watches jojo like in the old days
right they are the most
vocal fan base out of [ __ ] any other
anime fan base
and there's always the same [ __ ] we
want to talk about a dick measuring
contest like
jojo fans i actually feel sorry for any
musician who iraqi
chooses to like name him dude you go to
the comment section yeah
she's like the jojo fans have taken over
oh my god
which is like i call them locusts right
because because they like invade
they they take all the crops they take
everything and then they move on to the
next one
it's like the independence day aliens
right where they just like
they just like make this [ __ ] world
uninhabitable
and then move on to the next one did you
see when the star wars released their
new like r2d2 thing it was called dio
oh my god all the comments were gone
like oh yeah and so when connor was in
like peak jojo fandom this kind of came
out of nowhere
because he would just start making jojo
references like in everyday life and
like i remember in england we we still
hang out like pretty often yeah like
like once or twice uh every
uh well one a week or every two weeks
yeah yeah exactly and just
every time i would hang out with connor
he would just keep making jojo
references
he was like i i i thought jojo fans were
annoying
online hanging out with a jojo fan in
real life as a fan of jojo
made me start to hate jojo and i didn't
know that was physically possible until
household hang out with connor
like we would be like eating a meal in
like some italian restaurant
and connor would just be going through
this [ __ ] menu being like haha
proshito that's a joke character oh look
you ordered the black pasta this is like
that scene from part two where jesus
christ that's a jojo yeah and i'll just
be sitting there being like [ __ ]
i'm just trying to eat my [ __ ] pasta
can you not right now i remember i would
just do it on purpose at some points i'd
be like oh you
you approached me
and every time i just i every time
someone walks towards you
you would be like oh you're approaching
me you're approaching me oh
and it was like i'm so glad i wasn't in
the uk funny like the first two times
but like the 50th time of the night the
worst part was everyone at the party
started doing it
because i had done it so much that
everyone was saying
like they didn't know what even they
were even referencing most of the time
they were just copying yeah yeah
needless to say that i get it because
the passion for it when you first get
into like really into it is so
intense yeah and like you love
everything about it because
everything about that is so quotable
yeah you can take
anything out of context and it's
quotable i think that it's like the way
i try and describe it as like the
selling point is that like it's
such a unique experience in anime yeah
it is and a manga that you just
you nothing comes close i know everyone
says that but yeah it really is and i
think also because
being especially i think the reason it's
done so well in the west is that i feel
like it's kind of almost accessible
because a lot of the western references
make it really easy to dive it's because
iraqi as well has said that he's like
his biggest influence was western comics
and it's so cool because it feels like
it's like oh anime is like kind of like
acknowledging
us are kind of like yeah yeah yeah you
know
i [ __ ] love earth wind and fire and
when i first saw like the stand earth
wind and fire i was like i [ __ ] love
that
you know when you see a band that you
listen to it's so hype you know
and then when you see it again in part
seven you're like hold on a second yeah
wait did i do them
no it's like i think it's so easily
digestible in some ways and it's such a
no author does anything like this no in
any other way
and the absurdity of it but also it's so
dumb yet clever at the same time it's
really just an overall experience and
and such a good
style like yeah well that's why it's one
of the most parodied shonen jump titles
ever by
other shonen jumpers right like i'm
reading i shield 21 at the moment
and they [ __ ] when they throw the
ball some of them shout aura yeah yeah
and it's like just gonna casually
everything like literally every shonen
jump artist
has probably parodied or referenced jojo
in some way yeah
but it's like so unique so that's why
it's infinitely like
[ __ ] quotable and people can
reference this all day long and people
do reference this all day long
[Music]
which is which is what gets annoying at
some points because i remember when jojo
first started airing
like pops one and two i remember talking
no one gave a [ __ ] i remember talking
about it and i was like i think it was
like in my
very first year review when it's like
2013 and i was like
talking about jojo being like yeah
there's this like long forgotten anime
that's being
long forgotten manga that's being
adapted called jojo you guys you guys
should probably watch it
not knowing how big it would become
[ __ ] seven years later because now
yeah everyone in the anime community
knows jojo
but i don't think everyone in the anime
community should get into jojo you know
what i mean
it's it's it's it's hard like as much as
i love it i
i there's so many pitfalls that would
put someone off in the first few parts
yeah he's really coming into his own as
an author like i think part four is
really where he starts to be like okay
from part four onwards you're getting a
[ __ ] amazing experience
yeah yeah but there's so many growing
pains in between that yeah
and yeah it's uh part one and three
mostly i feel like they're growing pains
and i think that's also one of the
the annoying parts is that people who
love part two
then go to part three and they get
something totally kind of different and
it's hard to
like it's hard to adjust just like kind
of put up with it
like i i i wonder like if i had internet
you know i had any form of internet
would i have dropped it
like i wonder yeah would i because i the
only reason i watched it is i had no
other anime downloaded except for this
and i i remember being like
[ __ ] come on man yeah yeah this
[ __ ] fight's so boring yeah
yeah like come on and i don't know it
just feels like nowadays people will
still make jojo references and the jojo
phantom still acts like it's
it's this really underground kind of
show that everyone should get into and
it's just not that case anymore no
and i do yeah we are an annoying fandom
yeah i don't think
i don't think they understand that they
might be pushing a lot of people
away from the show and now just because
of how vocal they are
yeah i i like to now at least publicly
with my my jojo references i like to be
sparing
and like save it for a good moment
because yeah because jojo reference at
the right time
right that's the differently it does it
differently but like that's the thing
right is like i think as well that
a lot of people are just getting [ __ ]
sick of jojo's because
it is so quotable in any situation and
like so many of the jojo memes now are
just like
dude come on i'm just like dude come on
come on you can do better than that
like please like there there are a lot
of good memes there are a lot of good
i think it's i think it's like that now
because there's no new anime part airing
but yeah whenever there's a new anime
when part six like becomes an anime
whatever that may be the
memes are going to be [ __ ] top tier
yeah like we already know but in the
meantime there's just the dead moment of
just
dead memes where it's just kind of
putting the jojo fan base in a little
bit of a bad light i feel because
they're just
[ __ ] out these memes everywhere
people are just like you have to go a
bit happy i get it but like for you as a
jojo fan do you ever feel
defensive whenever someone shits on jojo
or like
oh it depends what fall like if they're
[ __ ] on it like just to [ __ ] on it
which many people
are because yeah the fandom's super
[ __ ] annoying yeah right so i mean
and it's a popular i mean
i get annoyed by it right yeah because i
read this [ __ ] and i'm like dude you're
12. don't talk on the internet
who gave you information yeah yeah your
profile picture is meliotis please stop
like i mean
it's hard right because it's like
watching your little brother like [ __ ]
his pants in public it's like come on
man
not now you're making me look bad yeah
yeah